c'est lié aux contraintes imposées à la
structure cinq groupes de six élèves de
représentants de chaque nationalité
et voilà la partie martiniquaise d'euros
boczko bruine lancer la fabrication
d'une serre robotisé pour préserver la
biodiversité
objectif du projet donc le projet et les
parties les parties donc en martinique
nos élèves travaillent avec l'abbé
déficit et martiniquaise
donc il s'agit de choisir un panel de
plantes qui pourraient éventuellement
planté dans leur chair les allemands une
fois arrivé là-bas avec la même serre
conçu ici modéliser ici un qui était
montreront qu'ils démontreront ils ont à
coeur de 10 m 2 dans le choisit un canal
de plantes de chez eux
une fois ces groupes constitués il a
fallu vite retrousser les manches d'ici
deux ans chacun d'entre eux devra
réaliser sa propre cerf un peu sur la
base du modèle martiniquais ici les
lycées et se penche sur le robot qui va
parcourir la serre et y effectuer des
relevés çà çà serbie pu piloter les arts
au vote
tout ça on va le mettre sur le robot
pour ainsi mieux paramétrer tout ce
qu'on aura comme valeur dans l'assiette
par exemple à nous avons un capture le
traçons pour les distances là on a un
écran pour afficher les différentes
valeurs on aussi une connexion bluetooth
installé sur le robot comme ça
l'utilisateur pour avoir justement les
différentes valeurs wilhem lui tous les
salles techniques du lycée joseph zobel
comme une véritable fourmilière
tous les groupes travaillent sur des
secteurs bien différent
nous sommes en train de faire un gabarit
avec une planche de bois pour après
faire un arceau avec des tuyaux pouvoir
créer la serre avec la bâche on est dans
le dans la construction de la ba de la
serre et foot c'est une particularité
bien visible dès les premiers travaux
martiniquais espagnoles et allemandes
aucun problème de communication c'était
l'une des crêtes vite retombée des
secouristes
les étudiants en 16 ans il parle très
bien anglais se comprennent pas c'est
très bien aucun souci d' incompréhension
informatiques et mathématiques chimie
une chose est sûre le projet robot au
service de l'agriculture séduit car il
intègre plusieurs disciplines ses
transversales sa touche à beaucoup de
matière il n'ya pas que physique chimie
a pas que svt
il ya aussi des maths pour pour les
calculs
les trajectoires qu'on peut calculer
dans différents thèmes de sciences de
l'ingénieur on doit faire des calculs
aussi en matière fissile dans les
prochains mois les lycéen martiniquais
iront à mosbah créé à valence toujours
dans le cadre de cette fabuleuse
aventure scolaire et humaine